so all this territory from the great
lakes down to the gulf of mexico between
the appalachians and the mississippi
river
is now part of the united states and one
of jefferson's proposals
is that slavery should not be allowed in
any of this territory
and uh i mean what an amazing proposal
when you think about it
because had it passed um the future
states of
kentucky and tennessee and alabama and
mississippi
and presumably louisiana and missouri
and texas
right would not have been slave states
and it fails by just one vote
all right so we declare independence
what's it like the next day do we have
any idea what happened the day after
like
you know what was he doing yeah well i
mean uh what was jefferson doing yeah
um you know jefferson continued on for a
while as a member of the continental
congress but i think that he
and you know his his great partner in
the
enterprise of independence john adams i
think both of them shared the sense that
now that independence is achieved um the
important work is elsewhere
the important work is not in
philadelphia um the important work is
is in william williamsburg the important
work is in boston it's in the
the capitals of these 13 new united
states
where we have the opportunity to come up
with new constitutions and
reform the laws and uh essentially
you know purge ourselves of monarchy
and become you know this nation of 13
real republics yeah so what was actually
his first job in government then after
that
um so we went back to uh to virginia he
was a member of the legislature he
soon thereafter became the governor of
virginia
um he served two uh two terms he
um he looked at reforming the laws um
some of his reforms were
were successful others were unsuccessful
uh
you know jefferson did not have a great
win loss record
as far as uh his legal proposals were
concerned interesting
the first bill that he um co-sponsored
as a member of the house of burgesses
you know in 1769
was a bill that would have made it legal
for virginians to voluntarily free their
slaves
and that measure was voted down and and
jefferson and his partner
in that enterprise were sort of shouted
down as as enemies of
of you know the colony yeah do you know
roughly what year that was
that was in 1769. okay 1769. so
so let's talk about his uh his feelings
about slavery sure and everything else i
mean
when when i've talked about this on the
show i say that as i said to you earlier
he was a complex man of his time he
owned slaves while he was writing laws
to free slaves
you know they address it monticello that
he probably had relations with at least
one slave possibly
or is that cleaner i know do we know
anything specifically
i don't think uh anyone so the woman's
name is sally hemings yeah
and it appears you know it's not 100
slam dunk but the evidence adds up to um
the strong probability that jefferson
and
and sally hemmings who was his late
wife's half-sister
um had a multi-decade uh monogamous
relationship
that yielded a number of children so i
mean
just in that description there's there's
a lot to unpack i mean she was
she was the half sister of his late wife
i mean you know this is like virginia
family trees
were oftentimes tangled vines and um you
know jefferson's father-in-law
was the father of of this enslaved woman
sally hemmings
wow and um when jefferson's wife passed
away
you know according to family accounts on
her death bed she made jefferson promise
that he would never remarry
in part because her mother had passed
away and her father
remarried and it seems as if um she
you know never really felt as if she was
regarded in the same way as her new
stepsisters
and she didn't want that to happen to
her own daughters
so jefferson made this promise um and a
couple years later
uh he's in france with his daughters and
he sends for
the youngest of his daughter to to join
them in virginia
um join them in france from virginia and
uh he by name requested this elderly
um african-american woman to accompany
his youngest daughter but she was sick
so his family back in virginia instead
sent sally hemmings to
to serve as a babysitter so you know
after her arrival at some point maybe in
france probably in france
their relationship began and you know
here's this
this woman who probably resembles
jefferson's
wife sally hemings is three quarters
white
she is you know from home right she
represents
family she represents virginia um
but she's also this this rare thing
she's you know a young virginian
who's with him in paris this incredible
metropolis
um there aren't many white women in
virginia
who have seen what sally hemmings has
seen who speaks some french
who've experienced this important part
of his life um
with him and and and so uh and he can't
legally marry her
right he can't violate his um wife's
promise with sally hemmings because
um by law yeah you know she could never
become his wife
god there's so much there all right so
we're obviously we're gonna sort of
bounce in and out of sure the slavery
discussion there
but so france was he the ambassador at
the time is that yeah uh he was i think
so i mean you know so he went over there
initially he was benjamin franklin's
understudy
and then when benjamin franklin uh left
france jefferson was elevated
to serve as our ambassador they had this
this weird term for it back then he was
our
minister plenty potentiary really yeah
that that is very fancy yeah so
give me just the uh the line
from uh working in the legislature in
virginia
to then becoming president just so we
get that sort of
peace out so uh you know he is uh the
governor of virginia
he then agrees to serve as one of
virginia's representatives
in congress um under the articles of
confederation
it's at this point in 1784 that
jefferson
proposes a law the ordinance of 1784
that is going to regulate
all this territory that has been
recognized as part of the united states
as a result of the treaty of paris which
ends the war for independence
so all this territory from the great
lakes down to the gulf of mexico
between the appalachians and the
mississippi river is now part of the
united states
and one of jefferson's proposals is that
slavery should not be allowed
in any of this territory and i mean
what an amazing proposal when you think
about it because had it passed
um the future states of kentucky and
tennessee
and alabama and mississippi and
presumably louisiana and missouri and
texas
right would not have been slave states
um and it fails by just one vote
now again at that time he owned slaves
he did
and this is why i think it's so
interesting and how we're all just
people of our time
do we know anything about his inner
thinking about that
like like i think there's a certain
amount of people and i've talked about
this with people
well why didn't you just freeze slaves
then yeah you know why did why didn't
you just let them go
so for for a while if if he really felt
that
abolition was the way to go for a while
it wasn't something that was legally
doable i mean
again as a result of uh the failure of
that first public act the the the act
to allow for the valiant voluntary
emancipation
so legally so for a while he legally
couldn't free them yeah
um and then you know by the time it was
legal for jefferson
to free them you could make the argument
that technically he didn't even really
own them
um jefferson inherited from his late
father-in-law
not only a large number of enslaved
people including sally hemings right in
her family
but also a tremendous amount of debt and
you know that debt
essentially just snowballed over the
course of his life he also uh
co-signed a loan with the governor of
virginia
who passed away so then jefferson was on
the hook for about twenty thousand
dollars of
of debt um he was also let's be fair he
was a high roller i mean you know
the largest library in the western
hemisphere doesn't come cheap
and you know he liked his furniture and
his art and his wine
and by the time jefferson died he was uh
i think about a hundred and five
thousand dollars in debt which in
today's money is you know between
like one and two million dollars right
and so his slaves really were owned by
his creditors
and um you know i i don't mean to
to say that to get him off the hook but
i think it's important to realize too
that
jefferson and the issue of slavery
are never going to be the only issue
right that he's trying to tackle
and when you get past the 1780s and you
know to go back to the trajectory of his
life
after he's done in france he's summoned
by washington to come back
um to the nation's capital and serve as
our first secretary of state
and we know that in the 1790s you know
jefferson is very quickly
going to get embroiled um in
disagreements with
you know his colleague secretary of
treasury alexander hamilton and and
jefferson
essentially views uh the constitution in
in a
in a specific sort of way he thinks that
if the constitution
you know gives the national government a
specific power then it has that power
but
you know if it doesn't specifically um
receive that power in the text of the
constitution he thinks that
um you know the the power should remain
in the hands of the states or the people
and
hamilton clearly has a different vision
yeah so so in our lens of 2018 he really
was a a
constitutional conservative right like
yeah he really believed if it's in that
text right that's the power that's
delineated but nothing else hamilton
felt you can sort of extrapolate yeah i
mean
hamilton thought that you know if if
something could be deemed necessary and
proper
um and hamilton you know has a point too
because remember the constitution
it wasn't created to make the government
weaker right i mean
it it was it was a victory for
nationalists and centralizers relative
to
the articles of confederation and
jefferson was was part of that i mean he
wanted
this new constitution to be ratified as
did james madison his chief political
ally
in the 1790s but they thought that
hamilton was taking it too far
um and that if this constitution was
going to mean anything
right it had to mean what it actually
said yeah and and so this struggle right
between jefferson and and hamilton
um is in some ways uh regionalized
and hamilton supporters are chiefly in
the north and jefferson supporters are
chiefly in the south
and you know i don't think it's a
surprise that once you get into the
1790s
by and large jefferson's actions against
the institution of slavery begin to get
muted
right because he needs to win this this
battle to preserve
the liberty of the new united states and
he really thinks that's what's at stake
and he thinks that hamilton is
essentially um this crypto monarchist
right that's slowly he's going to just
expand the government that he's a
counter revolutionary right
right i mean if we're going to preserve
the the liberty of white americans
um that that we can't then rock the boat
on the issue of slavery and
undermine right this coalition that he
and madison have created
which has its basis in the american
south if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell